hey their descendants fans we've got so
many ways to geek out with some
exclusive behind-the-scenes videos and
snapshots of the actors who play our
favorite villain kids watch until the
end to find out which villain kid
originally auditioned for the role of
Prince Ben recording studio babes one of
the best things about The Descendants
movies it's the musical numbers from the
very first film's opening musical number
rotten to the core fans were hooked the
songs were edgy exciting dance numbers
that really captured the villain kid
vibe then they took over auradon prep in
descendents two with ways to be wicked
and who can forget you must power song
what's my name we see the cast perform
these songs effortlessly in these movies
but there's a process they can be and
that all starts in the recording studio
that's right before dub puts on the
purple wig and distressed leather outfit
she jets over to the studio to put the
song down on a track every singing cast
member makes their magic in the booth
before they dance it out and film it on
set thankfully we've seen pictures to
prove it we found some behind-the-scenes
pics of Camryn voice sophia carson china
anne mcclain
and of course dub cameron singing their
hearts out behind the mice after they
record the song they learn a
choreographed dance number to go with it
then they get into their costumes and
film the performance of the number for
the movie dancer face off these big
dance numbers don't just spontaneously
happen they require a ton of prep time
in addition to sweaty rehearsals
mistakes and a few aches and pains along
the way but it all starts with director
Kenny Ortega vision of what he wants
each stance number to look like then the
choreographers snag the music straight
out of the recording booth and get to
work breathing life into the high-energy
dance routines the result is electric
mind-blowing songs that make bands freak
out with excitement the background
dancers came from all over the globe to
add flair and pizzazz to these big dance
routines and in the main cast members
and you've got magic choreographers
exclaimed that descendants opening
number rotten to the core had a dirty
gritty 70s funk dance feel to it it was
aggressive and unapologetically rotten
it had come out with a big bang because
it set the tone for the whole movie
dan sequence in d2 titled you and me
took place on a completely flooded yacht
deck water splashed around cast members
with every dance move this wicked cool
dance number required two huge water
cannons to spray the area the payoff was
huge
that number is totally unforgettable pre
filming Chan it's no secret that the
cast has become incredibly close during
the filming of all three descendants
films they've laughed a lot they've
cried they pranked each other and yes
they've become a family over the five
years they've spent working on
descendants movies of course when you're
that close inside jokes and special
rituals are bound to develop sophia
carson in the cast shared a special
behind-the-scenes secret about the pre
shooting ritual they performed before
each big musical number director Kenny
Ortega taught the cast a chant to get
them hyped up and ready to give it their
all in front of the cameras all the
dancers and all the cast would huddle up
into a big circle and do this chant
together china anne mcclain said it
helped the whole cast get amped before a
scene we're gonna go out on a limb and
say it totally worked
the musical numbers are full of energy
the dance routines are masterful and fun
and the billing kids add their own flair
of sass and passion to each musical
number who knew the power of boom
Shakalaka could be so incredible like
father like daughter Celia is one of the
coolest villain kids on the aisle she's
the daughter of doctor facili a this
girl has got some tricks up her sleeve
she's quick with a card trick and an
evil laugh and she's got a spooky sense
of style looking at her it's safe to say
she's a total daddy's girl at the Disney
fan fest actress who plays the role of
Celia Jada Marie revealed some
interesting details about her character
she said that Celia is 100% a daddy's
girl she added that Celia is a
mischievous little thing
according to her Celia is all about the
cash just like her dad for those of us
who have been speculating from the d3
trailers on whether Celia will be good
or evil this is a pretty big giveaway
but will Celia follow in her dad's
footsteps for good where will she go on
the same path as the og villain kids and
change her wicked ways
we know that then wanted to bring the
villain kids to Oregon but surely not
all of them are ready to let go of their
evil family history
maybe Celia is one of those characters
who remains rotten to the core
daddy blue hair Cheyenne Jackson plays
the role of Hades in descendant three
from the exclusive Hades trailer that
Disney released it's clear that he's got
a score to settle with felon B's Hades
feels this way because they decided long
ago to cast out those who didn't fit the
auradon mold he says that they forced
everyone who didn't agree with them away
to a crowded little island with no magic
no freedom and no hope then he added
that there's only so long you can be in
a place like that before it drives you
to madness or makes you hungry for
revenge but thanks to the king and queen
of auradon he has been relegated to the
lord of the underground and he's kinda
grumpy about it during the disney fan
fest Cheyenne Jackson shared that
playing this villain was a super fun
experience Cheyenne is a parent of two
year old twins he shared that when his
kids came to see him on set they weren't
mesmerised by his blue hair fans in the
crowd laughed when Cheyenne mentioned
that his kids called him daddy blue hair
my daddy blue hair that's very funny
the crew kicked them out dub Cameron and
Sofia Carson have been best friend gold
since the very first descendants movie
they've been through so much together it
makes sense that they wouldn't want the
filming of the last descendants movie to
end the memories they shared will surely
last a lifetime dub cameron shared that
one of her favorite memories occurred
during the last day of shooting their
last musical number in descendants three
sofia chimed in and shared that that was
purely coincidental because usually when
you shoot a movie you shoot out of order
but it just so happened that they shot
the final number on their last day dub
said that everyone in the cast was
really emotional because they all loved
the musical numbers so much they just
didn't want it to end so Devin Sophia
stayed long after filming head wrapped
he said they laid down on the ground of
the set with this massive green screen
until they were told that they had to
leave they stayed so long that the crew
had to kick them out but before they
went they shared a few laughs and a few
tears
so did a lot of reminiscing and took a
ton of photos late night grocery run
when you're busy filming a major Disney
Channel Original Movie it's easy to get
completely consumed by it all we
imagined there wasn't a lot of time for
the normal day-to-day stuff like grocery
shoppings booboo Stewart kind of
confirmed this when he shared his
favorite memory on the Disney fan fest
stage he said that one of his favorite
memories was the night that the cast
went out on a late-night grocery run in
their robes the night that they wrapped
production of descendant 3 a bunch of
the cast members went to the grocery
store in their roads that they took from
the set he stocked up on all the snacks
and delicious food they had been craving
they packed up their grocery store
goodies and crowded into one hotel room
where they completely picked out dub
revealed that more tears were shed that
night as well when you form deep
friendships like these you're bound to
wind up crying with a mouth full of ice
cream together at one point or another
saying goodbye it the film came to a
close was probably easier with a few
treats in their bellies it must have
been weird for the people in the grocery
store to see the cast in descendants
rollin up with a cart full of junk food
water bottle cakes do you guys remember
those awesome Apple cakes that Jay was
doing in descendants two during their
opening number ways to be wicked well
apparently that took some practice it's
harder than it looks
we just found some behind-the-scenes
footage of Jay showing his castmates how
to do that super cool kick move
then it was Sofia's turn she seemed
intimidated at first but connected with
the water bottle on the first try she
didn't seem to realize that she actually
made contact with the bottle
it wasn't until dub yelled you did it
that Sofia knew that she succeeded then
she did a cute victory dance to
celebrate after that dub was next to
give this kick move a try she looked
very sure of herself in the beginning
but she barely tapped the bottle with
her foot causing off-screen hysterical
laughter from a guy we can only assume
with Cameron voice her complete failure
to launch the water bottle didn't stop
her from showing off in a hilarious pose
the next time she tried it she totally
nailed it they have way too much fun for
it to be called a work impressions dub
Cameron and Cameron boys are undeniably
the cutest buddies we've ever seen it's
clear that dub adores Cameron and we're
pretty sure he loves her too like he
would a big sister it makes us that they
would be inseparable given that they
both have history with Disney and know
what it's like more than any of the
other cast members there's a hilarious
behind-the-scenes video of these two
trying to do impressions of each other's
characters and it's awesome first dub
tries to do an impression of Carlos but
she can't because she's laughing too
hard when she finally gets actual words
to come out of her mouth she explains
that his voice goes up and down really
fast
Cameron is laughing so hard at dubs
impression he almost falls over then
Cameron has an impression of now he gets
all emotional and says her line from the
end of the first movie when she says
both of them were rolling on the floor
laughing these two are always having a
blast together better as a villain
can you imagine what The Descendants
movies would have been like if booboo
Stewart had been cast to play the role
of Prince Ben instead of Mitchell hope
well at one time that was a slight
possibility according to an interview
with movie maniacs de bubu originally
auditioned for a different character
than the one he was ultimately cast to
play instead of jubu auditioned to play
the part of Prince Ben he said he went
into auditions countless times over a
period of several months before he
landed the role of Jays we think he's
way better as the sly sword wielding
villain
kid don't you Sophia Carson also
auditioned for a different role at first
to an earlier version of the script had
her reading the part of Gigi the princes
girlfriends we can only assume that
character is now the one we knew as
Audrey can you imagine Audrey's name
being Gigi we think we can speak for
everyone when we say we're glad they
changed it
dov also shared that the name on her
audition script was claudia instead of
now hmm doesn't quite have the same ring
to it does it what was your favorite
descendants behind the scenes moment
tell us in the comments section below
and if you're as excited as we are about
the release of descendants three
subscribe to our channel and give this
video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching the things see you next time
[Music]